[Music]
look what I become
all right so we got a special guest here
with us youngest of nine children in
media for 30 years decides to get into
politics runs for governor her opponent
and her had a debate with Katie Hobbs it
was the most watched debate of all time
because it never happened
record-breaking views and before I uh
properly bring her up I want you to
watch this video before we get into this
podcast go for it
reports out of Washington's a Kerry lake
is getting ready to run with an
announcement expected in October and
she's gonna probably run for Senate in
2024. I could totally see you in the
United States Senate what's the latest
are you going to do it she's going to do
some interviews starting in what
September or maybe an announcement is
currently going to get into this race
these are the questions what's next for
Carrie Lake
it is my duty to the citizens of Arizona
to stay in they think that I'm going
away they got another thing coming
[Applause]
[Music]
nice fantastic so we're gonna stay tuned
hopefully on this podcast with that
being said Carrie it's great to have you
it's so good to be here Patrick we're
locked in the vault this morning doors
closed everything's in oxygen levels are
perfect Mike's working uh we got a lot
of things to talk to you about uh folks
if you're watching this you fall in one
of three camps you either 100 no matter
what Carrie says you don't believe that
uh what happened in Arizona uh was fraud
you believe that she lost you're part of
the campus there's no way she won you're
either part of the camp that you know
for a factory one you're like no she did
win there was fraud done why were some
places waiting for five and a half hours
and you have to go from one place to the
other place and if you're watching her
election and you you were following it
close you saw her actually going to
different ballots and kind of seeing why
is this thing not working or are you
part of the undecided Camp saying look I
still don't know I just kind of want to
know the proof of what's taking place
regardless of where you are we're going
to talk about that today we want to talk
to you also about what happened with the
new Sun the Santa's debate actually
happened on Fox which is kind of weird
and in recent weeks Newsome's kind of a
gone away from the left and has gone
more to the center with some of the
decisions he's making what is he doing
there is there something going out there
you also made some comments about
Christy gnome about potentially her
thinking that she's going to be the VP a
lot of people are thinking you may be
the VP you're in a very very important
state but also before we get into some
of these issues I kind of want to go
back a little bit with you because I
think the audience needs to know the
evolution 30 years in media right you've
gone from being a republican to being an
independent to being a Democrat to
having a great interview with Obama it
seemed very friendly when he and you
were talking to each other was
phenomenal and then you become a
Republican and then you know even Obama
went after you Hillary went after you
holder went after you and you've made so
much noise you've had so many viral
Clips whether the CNN people have come
up to you and said hey we'd love to do
an interview and you said I'd love to do
it on CNN plus that was all over the
place whether it's you milking cows and
saying how many genders do cows have you
you're very very good when the camera is
on but before we get into some of the
issues today how did Kerry lake become
Kerry Lake
well if you want me to go all the way
back to my childhood I'm the youngest
child of a mom that was a nurse and a
dad who was a high school football coach
and a history teacher and government
teacher back when you actually taught
real history in real government and
um the youngest of nine children we were
poor growing up nobody really told us
that we thought it was normal to have to
work for shampoo and to buy our own
toothpaste we thought that was perfectly
normal but it was a great upbringing
because I learned how to have a work
ethic you know I had to work in order to
survive and to have the things I needed
so that was a great place to grow up in
Iowa and I grew up in rural Iowa after
the age of 10 my dad moved us from the
city to the middle of nowhere which I
called the middle of everywhere because
I think everybody should
experience what rural life is about in
this great country and so I grew up in a
little town outside of a little town
called Donahue which has 240 people
roughly and we live 10 miles outside
that town so going into town meant going
into a town of 240 people but it was
just a great upbringing and so I had to
work for everything I decided when I
decided to go to college at the last
minute I didn't even know how to go to
college I just said okay A friend of
mine said we should go to college
because what else are you going to do
I showed up and I went to college and I
um decided to work my way into a dream
job which is broadcast journalist ended
up working for about a year and a half
in the Quad Cities where I'm from and
then got called from Arizona to come out
there and I immediately you know became
a household name in Arizona and worked
my way up to being the number one news
face and news name in Arizona for 22
years I worked as the fox at the fox
affiliate owned by Rupert Murdoch and uh
during covid I kind of took my nose off
the grindstone for the first time after
working so hard my whole life and
realized that my industry
had really changed and was no longer
journalism I know some people say you
just figured that out during covid but I
always felt that even though the you
know journalism was liberal I could kind
of keep it straight when I was reporting
the news but during covet I couldn't do
that anymore I mean there was just this
push to divide people scare people push
us into our homes destroy our businesses
and you could not speak out with a
different perspective on that and so I
decided to walk away from my career you
know I made a lot of money I walked away
from a seven-figure contract my husband
is a saint I don't know where he is he's
probably outside the Vault right now
he's guarding the door open the door and
what was he the the straw that broke the
camel's back meaning prior to that Trump
for four years you must have seen the
writing on the wall on the media side of
things for the media bias right yes
absolutely and go back to when Trump
came down the escalator I remember first
of all I had I interviewed Obama one
year apart from my first time going to
the Trump white house so I saw the
difference in how the media treated
Obama and Trump because one year later I
went to the Trump White House and it was
like night and day polar opposite they
went from being lap dogs for Obama
everything he did every every policy he
did was just perfect to attack dogs with
Trump not giving him even a chance to do
anything so were some of these your
friends that are colleagues people that
you've known for 20 30 years yeah when
Trump came down the escalator I missed
that live and one of the guys in The
Newsroom came up to me was he doesn't
work there anymore he's I call him the
Socialist in The Newsroom and he would
probably agree that he was the Socialist
in The Newsroom and he was talking about
how terrible this speech was at the
bottom of the escalator and it was just
racist and awful and I thought
really I mean this can't be it couldn't
be that bad everyone in The Newsroom was
talking about how awful it was so I went
home that night found it on YouTube
watched it and it was like angels
singing I went oh my gosh finally a guy
who is speaking my language and the
language of the American people this is
what I've been looking for since I
registered as a republican in 1988 after
you know when I right when I turned 18
because of Ronald Reagan I was a hero he
was a hero of mine I was a fan of Ronald
Reagan's and then somewhere between
Reagan and Trump the Republican Party
lost its way it became the party of war
mongers and I know what happened I think
we all do it became the uni party that's
when the swamp reared its ugly head and
anytime anybody speaks out against the
war machine they get brought down
whether it be JFK whether it be the
attempt on Ronald Reagan's life and here
we had a guy who was audacious enough to
say I'm going to speak out against that
we don't want to start endless Wars we
don't want to have a wide open border
why is our economy not working for the
middle class I mean he said everything
that America was waiting to hear and I
noticed how the media immediately went
into attack mode and that was a a bit of
a wake-up call I mean I I was always
pro-trump and I on the air you have to
keep yourself neutral but the people
nobody around me was keeping themselves
neutral they were going anti-trump the
entire time publicly yeah it was
acceptable for the first time as a
journalist to be anti a U.S president on
the air
and I thought there's something going on
here did you have conversations with
your colleagues saying Hey listen let's
do our job let's be journalists not
activists like
pull back the the Wizard of Oz curtain
here what were the conversations like
within your own media business it's
really hard when you're a conservative
in the news business because you are
surrounded by I would say 95 of the
people in newsrooms around the country
in Legacy Media mainstream media are
liberal and so you you know you know
these people you like these people
they're your friends you work with them
for 30 years 27 years 20 plus years and
they're your friends there were some
conservatives and you try to kind of
when you go into an editorial meeting
yeah you try to kind of ease into it
you're hearing all of these stories
coming from a left bent and you try to
ease into them and go well wait maybe um
you know on balance we could also
interview somebody who has this
perspective so you try to kind of word
it that way unbalanced that was a famous
line maybe on balance we should do this
as well if we're going to cover that
story on balance perhaps we should talk
to so and so just to give it more
balance and by the way you're saying
that that's that's my interest because I
want to know what that world is all
about behind closed doors because you
know if you watch this video we've all
seen this video you've seen this video
as well this shows how you can press
play already they're all Unison on the
same message they're given
okay we've all seen this
oh yeah
Iowa communities Mid Michigan
communities we are extremely proud of
the quality balanced journalism that
cbs4 news produces but yeah
plaguing our country the sharing of
biased and false news has become all too
common on social media more alarming
some media Outlets publish these same
fake stories without checking facts
first the sharing of biased and false
news
so let this roll not the whole thing
okay pause right there right pause right
there okay so check this out this is
what's weird about and this is kind of
what I need your help with so you got
NBC there you got Fox there you got ABC
there you got CBS there you got it's not
like it's one or the other these are
different companies how are they all
saying the same thing are they watching
each other is it like you know is it
coming from the pulpit at the top or one
person is saying these are the words to
use these are the trigger words this is
what we all have to be United on this is
do like you know the mob had these five
families that at one point Italian mobs
they made this commission that the
gambino Genovese Colombo all these
families came together and then Lucky
Luciano was running it and Lucky's the
one that told everybody what to do to
make sure people are not killing each
other to make sure we kind of have
control of all the businesses together
is there a lucky in media Luciano that's
telling everyone what words to say and
what words not to say if yes who if no
why are they all using the same exact
script well I don't I I like the mob uh
you know comparison because there are
five or six families or entities that
are controlling the mainstream media
thankfully now we have alternative media
we have podcasts we have shows where we
can get information that's um that we
can that's more balanced for sure but
this is a situation where that's a
conglomerate that owns all those day
that's why you might see one that CBS
one that's NBC and I believe it was
Sinclair and the irony of this and I
don't want to stick up for this at all
because they're all saying the exact
same thing but I believe Sinclair was a
little more balanced and they were
trying to say look we're coming in we
own these stations everyone's gone
completely left and we want our viewers
to know we're going to be balanced we're
not going to push an agenda but in their
effort to put this statement out that
somebody at the top wrote
they they look like fools because
everyone said the exact same thing in
unison and and that clip was made but
the real truth about that clip is that
this was an attempt by I believe it was
Sinclair to tell Their audience look
we're going to try not to put our
opinion in
um unfortunately when they put it
together like that it just showed that
there's one huge conglomerate that owns
so many stations I don't remember how
many they owned we'd have to count the
boxes there but this is the problem when
I started in media in the early 90s
there would be a in in any given Town
there'd be five stations or three
stations and there would be a family
that owned one station maybe a company
owned another one and then during the
90s they started getting bought up so
you might buy uh five stations in the
Midwest and then you buy another 10 more
and you you cover the Northwest and
pretty soon you own as a media owner you
owned 30 stations across the country
that could be ABC CBS NBC because you
kind of whole you know hosting their
show and that's when things get really
um repetitive because I I even today I
get my news clippings every day and I'll
see a story about me and then I watch it
on another station halfway across the
state or across the country in its exact
same script different anchors are
reading it because it's one conglomerate
who owns all those stations that one
script that's coming from the top
conglomerate to say these are the words
we're using right and it goes on to
teleprompter you just read it right but
now this is the difference you know we
when I worked for Fox we would get those
same things the clips would come down
from wherever across the country other
other stations were doing stories they
would come to us the script is already
written but you can rewrite scripts if
you are have a good work ethic or you
don't like what they say you can rewrite
them so that it is different I didn't
want to just be repeating the same words
as somebody across the country you want
to look at that script and make sure
it's written properly not all anchors do
that so you you worked out of fox
affiliate when you were first getting
started you talking about a fox
affiliate you work that in Fox for the
longest time has been known as you know
Rupert Murdoch he just stepped away he
gave it to his son and you know he was
in the space for 60 years they had Roger
Ells they produced a lot of players over
the years O'Reilly Megan Kelly Sean
Hannity Glenn Beck Tucker Crossing
they've had a lot of stars at Fox and
they were known as the enemy to the left
they were known as the enemy you know
Fox is against uh American values while
we know maybe at many places fox has the
conservative values that America has but
the left would attack it all the time
and then you were on Pierce Morgan the
interview that you did a couple months
ago could have been even less than that
and you said you know Fox News is now
protecting the globalist agenda right
they're now a globalist media Outlet
when did you see as somebody that's been
in the space then making that transition
of just being some an organization that
we could go to for conservative eyeballs
to all of a sudden becoming a support of
the globalist agenda
well that's my opinion first of all I I
think that um they're a company and they
have the right to run their company
however they want they used to be
considered the conservative Network and
now I see them as they're pushing away
from America First Trump anybody but
Trump that's my opinion it looks like
they've gone toward the globalist agenda
this is the problem in America we've got
marxists on the left and we've got
globalists somewhere in that mix as well
the Paul Ryan's of the world I mean Paul
Ryan is a pretty top player over there
Karl Rove is a top player over there
these are the kind of neocon guys who
are into a globalist agenda right now
and so that's my opinion that's kind of
where they've gone they're moving away
from their conservative values and I
think they're moving toward more toward
being globalist conservatives if you can
put it that way when you say over there
you're talking about the world economic
Forum what do you mean the fox oh at Fox
yeah so before before we get into I want
to know because but they've made a
change they've definitely made a change
yeah I mean how often do you see the
Trump kids on hardly ever if ever when
do you think that happened I think that
they are anybody but Trump I think Paul
Ryan hates Trump that's my opinion
um and he doesn't want Trump that's why
they had they put all their money behind
DeSantis and now they're realizing
that's not working and Paul has that
kind of weight at Fox today yes really
wow and Carl who has more weight Paul or
Carl I think I think uh Paul Ryan has a
lot of weight over there I don't know
what his position is if he's chairman of
the board or what it is but he's got a
lot of power they got rid of Tucker
Carlson yeah that was kind of weird
because he was actually they they you
know my my thinking is going into this
election they know how important this
election is think about what the world
did to try to bring Trump down they did
a lot I mean the coven a lot of the
covid agenda was meant to in my opinion
disrupt an election Force mail imbalance
because they can't beat Trump based on
policy they knew that oh my gosh this
guy's going to be even more popular than
he was in 2016. he won the most votes of
any incumbent president in history that
that's why they had to go all out on Joe
Biden basement Biden and try to convince
everybody that he won the most votes in
history which is absolutely absurd and
the fact that we that people were
checked their intelligence and logic and
believed that is even crazier I mean Joe
Biden he's going to go down as the
greatest motivational speaker of all
time people that were trouble before we
talk about his motivational speaking
abilities let's go to our sponsors real
quick American Hartford gold folks
here's all I want you to be thinking
about I've owned gold for a long time
physical gold in many different
portfolios when the Central Bank in 2022
buys a record-breaking 1136 tons of gold
you have to ask yourself why that's what
happened last year according to the bank
of international settlement over 90
percent of central banks are working on
a cbdc American Hartford gold will ship
physical goals and silver directly to
your door you can also set up your a
gold IRA and roll over money if you do
have any kind of retirement funds
they'll show you how to protect your
savings and retirement accounts by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver they have the
finest products amazing customer service
and a buy back commitment and they got
thousands of five star reviews a plus
from Better Business Bureau tell them I
sent you and they'll give you up to five
thousand dollars uh worth of free silver
on your first order click on the link
below or call
866-939-698-4866-939-6984 or text pbd to
65532 once again the link will be below
so audience I opened it up and I asked
the question about three different types
of audience and you know there's an
audience that says uh Kerry's going
around talking about the fact that you
know she won and you know it's not fair
what they did and you know prove it
prove it prove it there's this whole
Community that's saying prove it prove
it prove it and say no she lost there's
an entire different community that
thinks you absolutely want and there
wasn't a there was election fraud and
then there are again the people in the
middle the independent the libertarian
the ones that actually want to say I'm
open to being yes or no but give me some
proof so recently this just came out uh
this was last week September 21st you
know this is from uh Carey Lake's third
trial to begin after unsuccessful
lawsuit challenging her loss in 2022 in
2022 uh Arizona governor race and it
continues to talk about
um
continues to talk about how uh where's
the page three here what page is that on
Rob is it five or six oh there it is
Carolina Republican contestant or loss
in 2020 to Arizona governor race is
headed to a third uh trial unrelated to
a defeat seeking uh to review all early
ballot envelopes with voter signatures
in Maricopa County a request initially
denied by officials there was a bunch of
videos saying this is not fair this is
not safe it's you know risk for people's
information to be out there then how are
you supposed to know if we can't see the
signatures right uh Lake previous legal
challenges included claims that
defective printers produce ballots that
were too light or too small and alleged
misconduct and the signature
verification process however she failed
to present sufficient evidence in both
trials with judges concluding she didn't
back her claims Lake's latest lawsuit a
public record case faces opposition from
counties officials who argued that
disclosing early ballot envelopes
wouldn't promote the best interest of
the state and could invite voter fraud
and identity theft Lakes two-day trial
will be held Thursday and Monday so so
where is it at today because a lot of
people were following it very closely
and the thing for me that was extremely
suspicious is when your opponent didn't
even want to have a debate I don't under
I mean if you're that confident in your
argument have a debate with characters
there's nothing wrong with that but that
never happened so where is it so far
right now with the progress you're
making with this 2022 Arizona government
well much like you said Biden was a
motivational speaker that's kind of what
my opponent is like makes sense if you
think us and Oz are motivational you
know she can't get through a sentence
without about 10 uh uh uh that kind of
stuff and we saw that whenever she did
speak on the campaign Trail which wasn't
very often and you know she ran she was
secretary of state so she had a big say
in how the elections were run in the
state we asked her to recuse herself
from that and she refused you know
there's so many unethical people in our
government but she knew that she would
be destroyed in a debate because she did
not have policies we had I had the
strongest border policy see the
country's ever seen and now we're
starting to see some of these Governors
who are spineless and won't do anything
now they're starting to go okay maybe we
do have an invasion at the border you
know it was two years ago that I put
this plan out Governors don't have to
rely on the federal government to
protect their citizens and call it what
it is an invasion go straight to the U.S
Constitution Article 1 Section 10 Clause
3 and protect your citizens protect your
state when you're when your State's
being invaded and frankly protect the
country because if these border state
Governors started doing something rather
than being part of the problem we
wouldn't have New York City overrun with
people here illegally we wouldn't have
fentanyl pouring into our country
killing people so you know that that was
her problem she had no policy she
couldn't speak she's just a puppet she's
not intelligent and they just wanted to
get her in office so that they could
control Arizona the cartels are fully in
control of Arizona right now the
Secretary of State Adrian Fontes is a
cartel lawyer former cartel lawyer and
we have an AG who took that position as
well and I know there might be people
out there who don't believe in election
fraud but we lived it in Arizona and the
majority of people in Arizona believe it
because they experienced it firsthand
they saw what happened they showed up on
Election Day and at six a.m when they
got in line so excited to vote they
don't trust the mail in ballots because
they saw what happened in 2020 with
Trump so the majority of people showed
up to vote and right away they were told
by the poll workers uh oh our equipment
doesn't work in 60 of the polling
locations and how ironic that it was the
Republican polling locations where the
equipment didn't work so we did fight it
afterwards we said something went wrong
here we know what happened lines were
four five even six hours long on
Election Day they would so one line went
almost a mile long
to vote and people were so mad when they
realized it's happening because there's
images out there but please continue
it's happening again I mean they were
they were there were people we have
video of people we took video right away
we said we've got to go document these
stories adults veterans people who were
tough guys who were in tears at what
happened
and and they stole this election I was
polling 10 11 and 12 points up the
internal polling that's the good stuff
the real accurate stuff
Katie Hobbs did not win and everyone in
Arizona frankly everyone across the
country knows it and when they say prove
it I am proving it why are the judges
not ruling against us I believe we have
massive corruption in our Judiciary if
you saw the case wrap up yesterday where
we're trying to get our hands on public
records which are these affidavit
envelopes the way that judge behaved
yesterday it needs to be put somebody
out there if they've got time I'm a
little busy right now need to take that
judge and every remark he made in our
two-day trial and loop it together
because I've never seen a judge behave
that way it was so dead obvious where he
was it was as if he was co-counsel for
the defense they don't want us to get
our hands on these affidavit ballots the
mail-in ballots when you send in because
they know if we do see those that there
aren't going to be signatures there's
going to be chicken scratches there are
three hundred thousand ballots that were
were injected into the system and this
is a whistleblower who told us this 300
1000 ballots injected into the system
with no chain of custody every time you
mail in a mail-in ballot there is a
tight chain of custody you can tell
where that ballot came from now nobody
knows where you voted or who you voted
for but they know where that ballot came
from three hundred thousand with no
chain of custody in the Arizona Maricopa
County 2022 elections that wasn't enough
to win to give Katie Hobbs the win so
they had to sabotage election day the
most egregious thing we saw when we
finally got our hands on the system log
files which is basically data lines and
lines of data that show everything that
happened in the election of Maricopa
County and we had our analysts start
looking through it was hmm what are
these three days of testing that were
done and we notice in the three day of
testing a lot of failures very high
failure rate sixty percent failure rate
of the machines 59 so we dug in a little
further and we said okay this is
interesting they did their testing the
required by law testing on the 11th of
October they brought the cameras in dog
and pony show and we found out that when
they did that official testing those
were on spare machines that they weren't
even using they then rolled the spare
machines back they don't use them in
three to over a three-day span the next
week they perform testing illegally no
observers no Democrat no Republican no
media they crack open the seal on these
machines they pull out the memory card
put a new memory card in and then they
start testing it over three day period
and they get 60 59 failure rate 59
failure rate it looks like a dry run
they wanted these machines to fail then
they took those machines and they rolled
them out on Election Day
and these people who tell me not to
fight this
is ridiculous we can't have our country
run with elections like this we can't if
we don't have Fair elections we don't
have a country and our elections are
theater to make us think we have here
let me ask this so first of all Tom
question for you and anybody here in the
history of Elections Governor anything
that's Governor Senate Congress
president any of those levels has there
ever been fraud where the person who won
a year two years three years later
it came back and showed that this person
cheated and won and then what happened
to that person we had that happen in
Arizona before a hundred years ago in
Arizona I think it was uh 1916. there
was a contested Governor's race and the
governor sat that one Governor sat in
office for a year and the courts finally
ruled that that was not the legitimate
governor and they put the other guy in
this happened in Arizona you've got it
there is that the president for why you
you keep pushing this meaning well I
keep pushing it because it's happened in
Arizona before so there's precedence so
this is sort of a motivating factor too
that's one of the cases that we cited in
our original court case but I'm I'm
fighting this because I want the people
to know that our elections are not
reliable they're not fair they're not
perfect elections like this you know why
I'm asking a question here's why I'm
asking a question has it ever been any
outside of that in the recent years in
any state actually in smaller and
smaller elections there have been in I
think there's a county in New York where
they deem that the county just was not
run the elections weren't run on the up
and up
oh boy yeah you know why I'm asking this
question the reason why I'm asking were
you going to say something Tom or no
yeah I think you go back to um Kennedy
Nixon and the the investigators that
were used by the Republican party this
is West Virginia and they went in and
they absolutely had them dead to rights
in West Virginia but it was Nixon who
said for the good of the country we
shouldn't contest this because they knew
but they didn't have like a stack of
facts that Illinois was carried right
they they knew what happened in Illinois
yeah yeah absolutely and that but West
Virginia look at how close that that
election was as close as Gore uh W bush
that election but do you know why I'm
asking this question I'm asking this
question for a couple different reasons
one is you know would we want an audit
to find out exactly if there was any
fraud and if yes okay if they have a
case in one state that happens then
another state wants to do it as well and
another state wants to do do it as well
and all those legal fees that you got to
spend in and maybe they don't want to do
it because they want people to trust in
the system so they're like look whether
they cheated or not it's done guys just
move on we don't want the American
people to lose trust in the you know a
voting system so let's just say that's
in my mind I'm just kind of processing
that you see why are they so worried
about this but okay fine let's say
that's one of the reasons number two
let's look at Solutions so if you are in
there whether it's a white house has
influence to be able to fix the election
so people can trust in it more or
statewise how would you improve the
system of electing well it really isn't
the federal government's job to improve
our elections it's state by state and
the state legislature and the
Constitution is the one that controls
the elections and we need to change laws
somewhere along the way when I started
voting I'm I'm dating myself here but
back in 1988 when I started voting we
had election day and our constitution in
Arizona calls for election day and
somehow it's become election month 27 28
days of voting and then they count for
up to two weeks until they get the
result they want the longer you drag out
the voting process the more there's
areas to throw fraud in and they've
complicated it it used to be a paper
ballot you showed up in a small Precinct
where there were 500 700 people on the
voter roll and it was really easy to
determine if somebody's like wait a
minute you're not on the voter roll you
need to go to your Precinct and vote
it's easier to control make sure that
there's not fraud slipping in but along
the way they realize that I believe they
realize that they can't win these
elections because they have terrible
policies that are not for the American
people and they've added layers of
complication
and for somebody so I think paper voting
uh one day and you count right there at
the precinct that way the count comes
from if you're in Precinct 27 it comes
from that Precinct at the end of the
night it's counted you send the results
to Central they tabulate all of them
they add up all the different precincts
and we have the winner that night this
is how elections have been run what
happened though how did it how did it I
I would why did it get complicated no
why I wouldn't be okay with 27 28 days I
wouldn't be okay with it this is what we
have right now but how do we have how do
we get here though was that covet was
that was that because of kova that they
were like listen people have to how have
the Amer how have the American people
been okay with it taking this long like
I can see Democrats being like wow you
guys just a lot of you guys
complain a lot of Republicans because as
long as Democrats went they don't want
to find like it's working right you know
what I'm saying so there's not a problem
for Democrats right at all okay then I
can see Republicans being like well you
know he's my it's not the guy I wanted
anyway so I don't give a you know
so there's some that are rhinos and
there's some that are establishmently
out so it's okay yeah he lost in your
face you know and
um great then there's the other
community that's going to be like the
independent saying yeah I don't I don't
know I don't know if I'm comfortable
with this I don't trust this I want to
know whoever won to win so my vote
matters so people don't lose credibility
and you know well my vote doesn't matter
why should I vote anyways they're going
to manipulate it anyway so I want to
know the people that actually want to
know for the vote to count they're not
okay with the taking 27 28 days
how did it get to that long of a time I
believe it really has been because their
policies are so bad this is an attempt
to make sure we have people in that that
are controllable I mean 27 days of
voting early voting and you look at what
happened when any state goes full mail
on mail-in ballots mail-in ballots
really are not secure ballots you know
would you put 500 in an envelope and put
it in the mail right now post office no
way no absolutely not but you're putting
your vote and now there's and they're
saying there's absolutely Hotmail though
if it's certified but it's not
unfortunately and um so any state that
has gone full mail-in immediately starts
to turn full left
look at the Washington State Oregon I
mean California is going that way when
you when you start seeing a loosening of
the voter laws and procedures
immediately the state starts to go
toward the left when you see when you
see uh laws that are adhered to that's
when you see sanity and you and you know
that you've got one vote you have one
vote I have one vote and why should
America care about this I've been all
over the country you know if you're in a
state Oklahoma for example I've been
Oklahoma pretty red State I believe all
50 states need to improve their
elections to make sure that they are
reformed and secure so we know that one
legal vote per legal voter but
um why should Oklahoma care about
Arizona's election fraud because even if
your State's running a pretty decent
election if Maricopa County one County
in Arizona runs their elections with
corruption and fraud your vote doesn't
count your vote for president Trump
because we know I I believe the the
country knows president Trump won some
people can't admit it but
your vote doesn't count if they're
watering it down with a bunch of phony
fake ballots in three or four counties
across the the country and look where
the world is going because we had that
fraudulent election in 22. we have Joe
Biden in the white house we're on the
verge of World War III it's like wake up
people we are on the verge of a war our
economy is in the toilet our borders
wide open our country's being invaded
how many more you know alarm Bells do we
have to go off before people go we've
got to deal with our elections you have
to look at the history of the precinct
system in American voting precincts used
to be fire stations schools Civic
centers and they were small precincts
were small for two reasons well a lot of
small precincts allowed people back
before we had two income housing
everybody driving to to work mom's
working and what happened was you could
walk to your Precinct you walked to your
fire station your school everything you
could vote small Precinct gives you high
control and you make a phone call okay
here we are here's the result 62 31 14.
and they the precincts dialed it in what
happened was on the mail-in ballots it
started with um there's a variety of
things and then they jumped on that
where because there's cracks where they
could leverage it it started with wait a
minute shouldn't our overseas military
get to vote in their elections well yeah
national election sure they should okay
well let's get them an absentee ballot
and that's where it was it wasn't
mail-in ballots it was absentee ballots
well yeah let's do that well
um then people started retiring and they
adapted it they started adapting you
know the voting rules well you know
maybe they're shut-ins or people that
can't make it to their Precinct let's
give them an absentee ballot and then
that was the crack where they said hey
you know what you know what we could do
Vinnie what if we just go the old folks
home and just harvest the ballots which
they did in Wisconsin
the whole world was these people who
candy they didn't even know their loved
one's name and they voted they can't
even feed themselves they can't do
anything correct and let's go look at
one of the first motions in Gore versus
bush in front of the U.S Supreme Court
the Democrats wanted to disqualify the
military vote that was absentee that was
coming back into Florida because there
were servicemen in Jacksonville Marine
Corps Air Station is down in Miami they
wanted to they tried to disqualify those
those votes and so you can see what
happened and Pat we went down the
slippery slope where hey you know just
mail-in voting let's make it easy for
everyone but there used to be reasons to
let the military let shut-ins have an
absentee ballot absentee ballot became
mail-in ballot mail-in ballot became
just an the wild wild west where Vinnie
and I could Harvest an old folks home
and then have them vote any way we want
or because now they're now they're
bringing him in for old folks home
Vinnie and I could just walk in at
midnight with ten thousand ballots and
say hey more mail-ins and they wouldn't
even question Us in the old days they
would say wait are these absentees for
military wait wait where's this all
coming from now you see the cracks
formed and there is the problem and
really quickly you Tom just said the
precinct voting was done at the fire
station or the church mainly churches
and schools I mean I could walk a block
or two to mine before
what closed during coven churches and
schools I don't think that's
coincidental and what else happened Mass
mail-in voting
this is uh it's really obvious when you
start when you start digging into it
what's really whatever was The
Mastermind behind the strategy I want
that person I care because I'm I'm a
pattern guy I always I look at patterns
other people call me different names but
I'm a pattern guy so like in your case
your opponent doesn't want to debate as
if they already know everything's set up
it's really weird right the machines
don't work people are showing up they
have to go to different places pretty
pretty weird the person that you're
going up against oversees the entire
election that's really really odd for me
then that umbrella that Pat was talking
about all the media makes you seem like
you're this crazy election denying Kook
the judges seem like they're in their
back pockets then we go back to like to
the Trump situation I see and it's
already starting to happen with it with
him because Hillary already is in front
of the news saying what pooing is going
to cheat did she sing the 24 election is
going to be rigged I'm like wait a
minute indict her yeah you play the clip
yeah and then and then carry so and then
already fauci Biden Bill Gates they're
all warning us about you know pandemic
two which is a perfect stay-at-home stay
in the basement you know I mean for uh
Biden somebody to vote do you think okay
if you had to guess do you think that
they're gearing up for something
for 2024 because it already seems I mean
Trump is kind of passing by them by like
10 if you had to guess Gary do you think
something because I mean if you think
about it a virus coming out of a country
that we own the lab comes out keeps
everybody at home you have to mail in
your ballots Joe Biden doesn't go in
front of a camera if he does it's in
front of like 20 people do you think
that something something wild is going
to happen to keep everybody at home to
have that same process happen I don't
know I'm I I'm almost thinking that they
know they can't cheat at the level they
would have to to defeat Trump and that's
why they're trying to keep him off the
ballot in numerous States they've got
sadly Republicans people with an R
behind their name trying to keep a man
of the people that the people want off
the ballot now because that tells me
okay why not just put them on the ballot
if they could cheat to that level the
People by the time the election rolls
around are going to be so fed up with
the way things are going that I even
believe
um we're moving towards seeing Democrats
disaffected Democrats who are waking
picking up that the fact that their
party is no longer the Democrat Party
who are going to vote for America First
policies the media will say they're
extreme policies he's an extremist you
know these Maga people are extremists
make America great again is Extreme yeah
wanting a secure border wanting to make
sure your kids and your kids and my kids
don't get their hands on fentanyl I I
don't know I don't think that's extreme
I think the opposite is if you're okay
with the Border being open that is
Extreme if you are okay with the United
Auto Workers not having an industry to
show up to work for because they're
going to ship our Auto industry over to
China to make EV vehicles and force you
into an evil EV vehicle against your
will because they're not going to have
you know this green New Deal is such a
ridiculous thing that's extreme if you
think it's okay to talk to our kids when
they're six years old or at a doctor's
appointment we just found out in Arizona
at the nursing school U of A they're
teaching nurses to at age three in the
wellness check at age three for a little
one to ask them about their gender
identity this stuff is Extreme and I'm
not going to be three years old at three
years old ask if they feel like they're
really a girl or I want to be a Cowboy
is that my identity I mean my son wanted
to be a dinosaur
I still want to be a dinosaur I actually
have a very uh direct question to you
um I actually believe that you're
actually a very uh strong attractive
candidate I think you you you have a
winning message everything you've talked
about
especially regarding immigration the
border the wall you're in Arizona for
the past 30 years not many people had a
plan to deal with the homeless you have
a lot of good things that you say
especially everything you talked about
with the woke agenda the LGBT the trans
we've talked about that on the uh
podcast
infinity times
um you have you have a platform I
believe that you know you you also have
what I would what Candace Owens called
the it Factor your media Savvy you're
attractive your hair looks great today
congrats even with the headphones on you
have a lot going for you
um why not focus on that more meaning if
you Google Kerry Lake and if you look at
any YouTube clip you you are the almost
face of election denialism so my
question to you is this uh you have so
much going for you even like SNL does
parodies of you my question is this uh
we saw what happened in 2020 or 2022
during the midterms any Trump back
candidate that doubled down on Election
denialism did not win uh you came
dangerously close to to beating hubs why
do you think that election denialism is
a winning message because at the end of
the day if you don't win you don't win
like Trump's not reversing the three
years ago election it doesn't seem
likely you're going to reverse this uh
election from 2022 you have so much
going for you so many positive qualities
why not just say listen I take my ball I
lost I'm gonna crush it the next time
and win rather than double down on the
loss why not well for starters I never
got into politics to have a big
political career I mean when people say
you're that you're going to hurt your
political career I frankly don't give a
damn about a political career and we
need to get people who are in this to
have a political career out of politics
and
it was a it was not just an unfair
election it was a fraudulent election I
don't walk away from a noble fight and
if I were to walk away from what they
did to the people who stood in line and
couldn't vote 200 almost quarter of a
million votes were rejected on Election
Day
almost a quarter of a million votes and
75 percent minimum were voting for me so
I look at those people they've reached
out to me and said please fight this
don't walk away from this fight if I
don't stand up and fight for them they
don't have a shot at fighting this fraud
in the elections I'm a Mom first and
foremost if you have a problem in your
household and I think how many of your
dads
okay
um if you have a problem in your
household you don't you know if you have
a problem in your marriage if you find
out your teenagers are getting into
something dangerous and you need to deal
with it you don't put your head in the
sand and go well let's not look back
let's look forward things will get
better things aren't going to get better
if we don't have Fair elections but
Carrie with all due respect that's not
what wins elections what wins elections
whether it's Trump in 2016 whether it
was Obama in 08 whether it was George W
Bush in 2000 is let's do something great
to make America great again let's look
to the future the future looks bright as
we say sell me the dreams sell me the
dream and I believe you saw hey three
years ago this happened last year this
happened it's been proven that it
doesn't necessarily work
I'm getting a noble fight into a
platform decision I'm not I'm saying
that she couldn't win platform decision
this is a noble excuse me let me ask
Kerry her question whoa so I'm asking at
what point the man who never
I agree with parts of what you said and
I look back at our Campaign which is
when I got into politics I don't know
how I ended up in the middle of the
political world but I did and we had all
that I I my number one platform issue
was not elections it was we've got to
secure this border totally agree and
these Governors are doing anything and
they're failing at their duty to the
people I had a great policy on education
and I'm I'm again dating myself here but
we used to have trade school training in
our high schools got rid of all that and
now we're doing Dei and CRT and trans
agenda we need to get our kids
especially our boys ready for real jobs
out there policy on that great policy to
deal with our chronic Street
homelessness and we you I can go down
reshoring
manufacturing to Arizona with our
proximity to Mexico it's a great great
opportunity to grow and expand the
economy in Arizona excellent policies
and they knew that oh man this woman
means business she's going to shut down
our illegal activity our trans uh pardon
me um trafficking of drugs and children
and human beings and they had to stop me
and so we have to deal with what's
happening in our elections and reform
our elections and this is uh you're
reading Google and all of these articles
are written by a slanted media that has
completely gone off the hinge
propagandist and they're writing all
these and saying she's an election
denier and nobody's for it I'm out there
with the people every day I have been
all over this country everywhere I go
even in Portland Oregon I think I got
stopped more in Portland Oregon people
saying thank you for what you are doing
you you've got to fight for elections we
don't have a state anymore they're
ruining our state and we can't vote our
way out of it anymore we've gone full on
mail-in ballots they're destroying
Portland they're destroying the entire
State now and we are stuck were held
hostage by rotten elections and I want
to say something here okay I want to say
something here I fully you know I asked
this question of Rudy Giuliani so you
know where I stand we had this live
debate and I'm asking Rudy Rudy you keep
talking about fraud fraud fraud it's not
an attractive thing to do here's what's
going to end up taking place you know
people want to know what is the plan
great but I actually have a question you
ever watched the movie Flash of Genius
no uh it's the story of Robert Kearns
okay so who Robert Kearns is this is the
guy that invents the intermittent wiper
because he had a he had a hard time
watching when it was raining so the
wiper wasn't fully I love that guy I
didn't know that was him that's him even
Mitten wipers are one of the Great
Inventions but I gotta tell you he may
end up being your biggest source of
inspiration I think you got to watch the
movie Let Me Explain why so this guy
Robert Kearns invents it goes and takes
it to different car companies okay he
takes it to uh Ford he takes it to you
know this is the movie he takes it to
Ford he takes it to Chrysler what these
guys do is he gets a patent in 1964. he
patents this in 1964. Fort sees it says
this is an insane idea but guess what
Ford does Ford takes it and says you
never came up with this we did it
ourselves and they showed they said
there's only four pieces to this thing
this is not a big deal we did it
ourselves and in court there's a scene
where he's telling the judge says judge
have you ever used the word book yes you
ever use the word philosophy yes you
ever used the word uh I have yes how
come you've never written another uh one
of the greatest books of all time that
Charles Dickens did he has access to the
same words you did but he knew what
words to pick to put together to write
the greatest one of the greatest books
of all time he says it's not about the
pieces being this simple I found the
right four pieces to use to put this
together watch what ends up happening
this is my uh he ends up uh fighting
forward and Chrysler goes to court loses
his marriage loses his kids loses
everything he has eventually Ford offers
him 30 million dollars and by the way
this is not 30 million dollars of
today's money this is 30 million dollars
of 60 70s money it's real money wow you
know what he says he says no he says
they give him 30 million to say he was
at fault Ford wanted to give him 30
million dollars to go publicly and say I
was at fault he says I'm not doing that
you ruined my life I invented this
product I'm going fully on with this
thing here he ends up winning instead of
getting 30 million dollars he only gets
10.1 million dollars but Ford had to
publicly say they were at fault Chrysler
later on had to end up paying him around
18.7 million dollars and his story
became public I think for somebody to
prove there is fraud they're going to
destroy your life okay and I think
someone's trying I think someone has to
do it because I think it is
inspirational for someone to take this
kind of a risk for the longest time this
guy's own family didn't believe him
there's there's scenes of his kids
questioning that Dad why are you doing
this we're losing everything because you
have to use money for legal fees and all
this other stuff you're you're crazy
you're nuts you're this
I believe that I don't have all the
Intel I don't know what happened there
I'm extremely suspicious extremely
suspicious you need 27 28 days for what
my kids can count up to you know 100
000. you can't count it in you know one
day or two hours or three hours with all
the technology that they have the person
doesn't show up to debate so all I'm
saying is I think if this is truly
something you want to go fight for I
hope you go all the way through because
I think there is a reason why no one's
ever done this because they're gonna do
whatever they can to destroy your life
they're gonna do whatever they can to
destroy your life but whoever ends up
proving it the rest of the American
people will be protected for decades and
centuries to come because they're always
going to go back and say the Kerry Lake
case the Kerry Lake case the Kerry Lake
case just like this guy here you know
Robert Kearns who did what he did so by
the way I don't think uh it's gonna be a
fun fight I think it's gonna take it's
not yours I don't think it's going to be
solved in three to six months I think
it's going to take a different president
to come in to want to have to
investigate this to want to encourage
that we want to change the ways we're
handling elections to appoint different
people that can investigate that are
private not just public but all I'm
saying here is so you're making a very
good point yeah it's probably not an
attractive thing to campaign on if you
want to win public office so here's a
question for you here's a question for
you what's more important to you
um
becoming a senator or becoming a
governor and none of this stuff has ever
proven or you never become a senator you
never become a governor you never become
a VP but in the next three five ten
years we finally find out there was
fraud here and for anybody else in the
future that runs is protected which of
those two is more important you know the
answer I want to hear it the latter and
I'm never going to stop fighting I'm
never going to stop fighting for honest
elections reform in our elections we've
walked away from far too many fights and
that's how we've gotten into this
position and sadly the Republicans have
walked away we need that's why president
Trump is so loved it's like finally we
have a fighter
is he perfect in every single way no and
I don't think any of us here or anybody
listening is but he fights for us every
day and I will fight as I've said we
surrender so many Hills we're on our
final Hill I'm going to the top of it
and if they want to stop me they're
going to have to go up to the top and
take me down I don't care about money I
don't care about even getting credit for
saving our elections and reforming them
I really if I go to my grave and I know
that my children and at that point
hopefully great grandchildren maybe
great-great-grandchildren have a
republic to live in with a constitution
that is adhered to with a Bill of Rights
that actually exists
I will be the happiest human being even
if I'm penniless
even if you're pendulous we what good is
it are you seeing what they're doing to
Rudy Giuliani oh I I was just with Roger
Stone last night do you know who they're
coming after everything I have right now
they're suing me for defamation for
Having the courage to speak out about
our elections they're not going to stop
and they won't stop but that's okay what
good is that money if we lose our
country so here's our choices you're
what you're saying right now is
you could just be quiet and keep the
money you have and all of that but then
we're going to be a year out from now in
a I believe a communist globalist
country we're not we're losing our
American freedoms we're losing them
every day if you haven't noticed and
what good is that money living in that
if we don't have our freedom and so we
need a few people who are Freedom
Fighters right now and you know as long
as I have enough to eat
I'm I'm okay with that I I don't even I
don't need that much I don't I don't
think the dirtiness has started with you
yet I think they're they're uh banking
on you stepping away from this and I
think they're banking on you quitting on
this and moving on to Senate and
allowing Senate to be the next
distraction because when they look at
people like you and what I mean by
people like you is the fighters they're
you're very annoying you're very
annoying in the way when you fight
somebody that's why in the ointment
a True Believer is a very annoying
opponent very annoying point you you
like to face people that can be bought
with women with girls
they tried to bribe me right came to my
door and tried to bribe who did I'm not
going to name names because I don't and
people say why won't you name the person
and I said because I don't want to shoot
the messenger came to my door called me
one day and this was back when I was
finishing up my book which is called
unafraid I highly recommend it
um and said you know can I come over I
got to talk to you about something but
it has to be in person I can't do it on
the phone and I thought okay that's a
red flag what's going on here was this a
person you knew already it's a political
figure that's a big name that's known
um I think in some circles yeah and
showed up and said look look we want you
this is probably March
um so our case it was I think in the
pellet Court we were you know continuing
March of 23 March of this year it might
have been February so meaning this is
several months after the 2022 election I
was still fighting I was just rapping I
think it was March because I was just
finishing up the book got it and put you
know doing some final edits on it and I
was trying to pack to get out the door
to go to CPAC I was going to be
delivering a speech at CPAC and person
comes over sits down
and says um got a great offer for you
coming from some pretty powerful people
back east
great position great title uh huge
salary position on a board and all they
want is for you to not run again in this
next election just one election cycle 24
not be on the ballot
and I I was just I mean shocked that
this was I'm thinking this is the kind
of stuff you have happens in movies
right
and I said well why don't you go back
and tell them that I'm not motivated by
a job
I'm not motivated by a a powerful
position I'm not motivated by money I
walked away from that I truly walked
away from my dream job
because we're losing our country so the
conversation went on tried to convince
me just once it went out you can always
get back in I don't think they want me
on the ballot in any position in Trump
because if my movement comes out to vote
in Trump's movement all of the rhinos
and globalists or whoever they're going
to put in are are going to go down and
so I I shooed the the guy out because I
said I've got a pack I'm finishing up my
book as he's leaving he turned around he
said what would it take how much would
it take for you to just not run in 24.
and to be honest I was so consumed with
writing the book at the time I was
finishing up you know travel plans to
get out of the house I wasn't really I
mean people had talked about me running
for Senate and I've given it a lot of
thought and if they are willing to steal
an election from the good people of my
state
to bring me down and get me out I'm not
giving him that
that gives them the Victory and I'm glad
that Trump is willing to stay in as well
because they took it from him and if he
were to say look it's too hard they
might ruin me they might take all of the
money I have and leave me in Ruins if he
would have done that then they went is
this a person that's part of the
establishment right
I really don't want to give too many
um here's why I'm asking a question okay
but you have proof like if if they came
to destroy your life you have proof of
this situation taking place
yes but the person who delivered the
message was not the person behind the
offer but the person told you who was
behind the person just said it was
powerful people back east and East as in
New York or DC I'm thinking this one
okay I got you so so so so so so where
I'm going with um where you're right
right now so you're saying you would
rather fight for your beliefs on what
happened and give up every other
possibility of what you could do to go
prove that you were right okay so I
think they're thinking you're going to
give up quickly I think they think you
guys I don't think they think that now
and by the way there will be more
lawsuits to come we're working on other
things in their eyes in their eyes
there's been a hundred of you trust me
they're arrogant people who they they
think there's been many of you and they
know how to distract people like you
with other distractions and then all of
a sudden they're going to be like yeah
her fire could because you know emotions
are always high when you first go
through a breakup right yeah so you cry
you only get God this is odd who is he
dating who's she dating I don't know let
me check her Instagram his Instagram and
two months later like oh man I wish you
nothing but the best and we kind of move
on right yeah only a few people are like
oh hell no he did me wrong she did me
wrong okay so so in a situation like
this for the most part most people move
on right
um their banking you're gonna move on
with another run that you'll go on
that's what they're banking on I think
so and if you choose to keep pushing to
find out and get to the bottom of this I
think what you're experiencing so far of
them destroying your life is one tenth
of what they can do uh just this morning
you know who Giuliani got sued by who a
guy named Hunter Biden
Rudy Giuliani over laptop accuses
ex-trump lawyer of hacking Biden alleges
Giuliani is responsible for the total
annihilation of his digital privacy
claims there was no laptop
um so it may be he just sued I think
Garrett Ziegler for for you know putting
all of that together and explaining what
was on the laptop he also sued the IRS I
mean he pretty much sued his dad right I
mean that's good do you think about his
dad's employees he suit but okay let's
let's go away from this story here today
uh uh you know strategically VP you've
answered this guy watch answered 40
different times and I know how you're
going to answer it you know you know uh
uh you know my job is right now as a
mama bear to protect and you know that's
what I'm doing it's not about being a VP
it's about doing my job I may run for
office all this other stuff okay so VP
you're in a very important state okay
and you also said to peers I think he
needs to choose somebody to do the
fighting for him like in other words he
needs a flag interior Mike Pence wasn't
a fighter for him and that was a first
term VP which I think Mike was a very
good first term VP minus the covet when
he did what he did but for the most part
he brought a good state to him it was a
necessary state to him Mike did his part
second term it's about who's going to
replace for the next eight years after
him he needs a true flag carrier that
can fight go do the part do the legwork
defend him almost kind of like doing
what kellyanne Conway did I don't think
he wins 2016 without Kelly on Conway I
think kellyanne common was a rock star
right I think she was a rock star it was
so hard not to like her when the media
was horrible to her that's when I woke
up really frankly with Kelly they told
her I learned a lot she always kept calm
yeah she always helped me at home she
really isn't and they were being so rude
to her and she just came out looking I
see the same with the two of you that's
why I'm asking so so do you think one
you would be a formidable VP candidate
because you're also in a very important
state and you have a lot of you know
what the dead bodies are buried in
Arizona so if something happens you guys
can also follow up on the things that
you want to do to make sure it's proven
what happened in Arizona
you know one obviously if you got the
call would you take it too you know who
else do you think would be a formidable
VP candidate for president Trump I know
you can't speak on his behalf but I'm
just thinking if you had something so
many things to talk about there first I
want to go back to what you just said
before this and then I would promise him
an answer sure you can run and you can
do a lot of things and have lawsuits and
so I'm a multi-tasker I'm a mom I can
handle you know I'll never give up on
fighting for your vote whether you are a
Democrat independent or republican if
this would have happened on the Democrat
side and Trump would have won the way
one the way that Biden won I wouldn't be
okay with that either this is about
saving America
and our founding fathers many of them
were penniless at the end of their fight
to bring us this great Republic and I am
motivated by that Spirit okay so that's
that well let me say something to that I
know you can save in America I put an
event together in 09 called saving
America doing the impossible I'm dressed
as George Washington my wife is dressed
as Lady Liberty I have a 40-foot Mount
Rushmore on the stage and the whole idea
was We're Gonna Save America that was
the entire campaign so we started a
Facebook page uh in 09 called save in
America and I had a radio show on kkla
KR Lee called saving America back in
2009 2010. I that's that's the guy right
there that's the Middle Eastern George
Washington right there July 17 2009 okay
that that is racist okay
I can't believe
that's not your wife is that your wife
my wife is in another big it's very
it's very short but she she's dedicated
to the costume so great so so thank you
on that let's save America but go ahead
to your other question with the VP site
all right the VP stuff I get asked that
I don't think president Trump's thinking
about VP honestly I just had a great
conversation with them the other day I
always will take a call from president
Trump I think he's the greatest
president in our country's history and I
believe he will go down as one of the
greatest
political leaders and leaders frankly in
human history yes I said that why do you
think he's the greatest in American
history above George Washington above
Lincoln above JFK you think Trump is the
number one of all time Washington was
great absolutely obviously our first
president and he was a great General who
helped helped us even have this Republic
but we're losing this country I believe
we have about a year left and the person
who saves this country pulls it back out
of the Flames is going to go down in my
book as the greatest president because
what good is it if we lose the country
and it ends this year it's like okay
well Washington was fantastic thank God
for Lincoln thank you well Lincoln
literally saved the country not you know
hypothetically yep but we're losing it
now I I believe not as bad as the Civil
War though okay I don't know I think we
could end up going down as not having a
republic they want our constitution gone
they want we already I've never thought
I'd saw a day where our first amendment
would be in the crosshairs and it is
we had our churches shut down we've had
we do not have freedom of speech right
now we have a people think we have
freedom of speech but if you only have a
little bit of freedom of speech and some
people have a little less and some
people have more that's not freedom of
speech guys and the fact that we have
journalists I call them journalists who
use that term loosely who are okay with
it I mean they should have the
journalism card pulled immediately that
they are not fully for the First
Amendment whether you like what
someone's saying or you don't and our
government is working with these Tech
tyrants to take away certain people's
right to speak so but back to me
can I get my VPN so with zero
Interruption okay please go so would I
accept that position
is that what the question would you and
who else you think is a formidable
candidate for VP
I really want to make sure Trump gets
his second term
and I think looking even even
considering that right now is so off
base when we got to make sure he gets
that second term and so people who are
kind of like
you know Jones and to have that happen
or jocking for position are so in my
opinion
uh it's almost insulting because it's
like we've got to do everything we can
to get him in office if if he gets in
office and I have no place in his orbit
as long as he's in office I'm fine with
that I'm not doing any of this I don't I
don't get asked to speak out in his
favor I don't get told to speak for him
I speak for him as a mother who's really
really concerned about my children's
future in a very selfish way I'm
concerned about my kiddos and so I speak
for him for that if he called and asked
me I'd have to really consider it but
I'm really looking at a different
position right now and I think when you
played that video which thank you it's
on my Twitter page right now it
insinuated that something might be
coming in my world so what's next we
have an opportunity to pick up a senate
seat right we have a senator right now
Kirsten Cinema who's now in her election
mode Kirsten Cinema Who's acting like
she's independent which is such an
insult to the intelligence of the people
of Arizona we've watched as for five
years she's voted in lockstep Joe Biden
and Chuck Schumer on everything and you
know even though they name this you know
the inflation reduction Act
I think people are smart enough to
realize that it usually means the
opposite of whatever the Democrats name
these yeah it means watch out hold on
hang on with both hands because you're
not going to be able to afford basic
groceries and gas anymore and so she
votes in lockstep with him she votes
with Biden more often than uh Bernie
Sanders does and now she's trying to
reinvent herself as an independent she
shows up in DC she dresses in a wears a
purple wig on the floor of the Senate
and go-go boots and she shows up on this
stage with at the wef in Davos and now
she wants to come back and act like she
is with the people of Arizona she didn't
give a damn about the border now she's
on the border we recognize BS when we
see it and I don't want to see her go
back and represent the people I also
don't want to see the guy on the
Democrat ticket who is a full-on
socialist slash Marxist these are not
the values of the people of Arizona
those two have done nothing to secure
our border they voted to impeach Pres
president Trump while they're letting
the Biden crime family get away with
murder and so I'm very seriously
considering a run I think the video
insinuated there might be something
coming up here and we're going to take
back our country and we're not going to
surrender another Hill I don't want to
see another Mitt Romney type in DC
voting against the American people when
we get Trump in office we got to have
people there who are going to help get
this agenda to save America past so
Senate so a couple of the issues that's
going on which is uh you know Arizona's
border crisis the amount of people that
are coming through on a daily basis you
talk about the cartel early I do want to
address the cartel issue cartels are
significantly profiting from the illegal
border crisis the uh migrant smuggling
economy who wrote that by significantly
profiting Washington Times okay so
economy making a killing on it yeah at
the U.S Mexico border tops 20 billion
and the cartels have made at least 2.6
billion in profits over the past 12
months uh uh just from controlling the
route's illegal immigrants use and on
top of that last year the Department of
Homeland Security estimated that cartels
are earning up to 6 billion a year just
from Human smuggling operation this is
not like a website saying 6 billion year
this is from Homeland Security so what
are some strategies you're going to have
to make sure you protect that
specifically in the state of Arizona
well I talked about my border plan um as
governor and that I think every governor
should take it it's out there on the
internet it's called defend Arizona but
you could easily say defend Texas defend
California that's never going to happen
with uh Newsome defend New Mexico we
need strong border Governors to do right
by the people of this country that's why
people were rooting for me across the
country they said finally one Governor
is going to do something about it so we
really need the governors to step up
right now until we can get some you know
quality individuals put into Congress
and we do have some by the way I don't
want to say everybody in DC is rotten
we're getting some great fighters in
there but I think we need to immediate
get president Trump's border plan back
as a journalist I covered Arizona for 27
years I'd never seen that border more
secure than under President Trump I mean
he found a way and he had to do this
mind you really with one arm tied behind
his back with his own party people who
had an R behind their name attacking him
they would not let him build the wall
they were fighting you know he had to
like get very creative to get the
funding for the 500 plus miles of wall
he put up and I've been to the wall it
works now Joe Biden has opened it up and
welded it into an open position and tens
of thousands of people are pouring
across every week in Arizona and the
drugs are pouring through and we
actually have cartel members crossing
the border armed and they they know they
own the border the cartels own the board
of the owner state right now so it's
really easy we just need to get Trump's
policies back in at a federal level and
if Joe Biden wants to call them the
Biden border plan I don't care what he
calls I'm sure Trump doesn't care just
do it to save our country uh and Kerry I
have a really quick question so I know
of the vet yesterday or the day before
was that I was on his uh Twitter Rob uh
he was you know out there campaigning he
walked into a coffee shop and a lady
asked what would you do you know about
the board and Vivek said you know as the
commander-in-chief you have the right
you don't have to ask for permission to
put our military
I'm a veteran Patrick's a veteran we
have people that are just I'm not
they're not there's no active crazy Wars
going on right now we have soldiers that
are literally just you know waiting
around and whatever why not use that to
protect our board instead of protecting
you know others people's borders uh
around the country would you be able to
have that as as Senator to have that
type of authority to put away my actual
border plan as governor was going to be
to put the national guard down there
good and we have men and frankly women
but men would come up to me all the time
and say I fought for my country if if I
just got the call to go protect my
country right now I would be there in 20
minutes I would be down I would be
heading to the border to protect my
country men and women in this country
want our border protected we don't have
a country without a border and we're
sending our sons over overseas to fight
Wars because there's trillions of
dollars in these endless Wars that's why
frankly I believe that's really why they
want two reasons why they want to bring
Trump down he's not going to start it he
didn't start any wars he resisted
starting Wars there's trillions of
dollars in Endless Wars with the
military-industrial conflicts that JFK
warned us about
um I believe it was Eisenhower warned us
about I mean Eisenhower on his farewell
speech so there's a lot of money in that
anybody that speaks up against them ends
up gone or destroyed so I might you're
right I might end up destroyed but the
other thing is I don't want to see our
sons and daughters fighting these wars
overseas when our own country needs help
I believe some of the stuff you say is a
complete winning message I think you
have great messaging I've told you what
I thought doesn't necessarily win
um here's my question to you I think
you're a great surrogate for Trump I
think you have a lot of kellyanne Conway
Moxie for sure in you
um
if you were going to be the VP I think
if you look at the polling I look at
Vegas polls I don't trust Quinnipiac I
look at Vegas polls because that's where
the money is you're in the top three and
a lot of people said that I was going to
win in a landslide well sometimes Vegas
loses and then they have to pay but um
but the point is you're you're at the
top of this list put put on your
hypothetical you know take off the mama
bear hat and put on the VP hat you know
you're gonna be in the Oval Office with
president Trump you've already said you
think he's the greatest president of all
time you're in the office you know
you've had the Mike Pence's of the world
to build bars of the world the general
Kelly's people that have been in his
insulated in his Circle that have
disagreed with them and they are for
whatever reason or not so much in the
Inner Circle if you know what I mean
let's say there's a scenario where you
totally disagree with President Trump
and you
you you don't advocate for what he's
advocating but you do you need to remain
loyal in order to kind of keep your
position there how would you handle that
Nuance like give me some insight to how
vice president Kerry Lake would have
that difficult conversation with
President Trump if you actually disagree
with him on something well first of all
when when President Trump says he
appreciates loyalty he doesn't mean
loyalty but you never ever speak against
what I am I want that's not what Loyalty
means Loyalty means you know he's done a
lot for a lot of people
and I will tell you I understand loyalty
when someone stabs you in the back you
want the people around you that you that
you can trust them not that you trust
them you bring them in and then they
turn around and walk out the door and
stab you in the back it's really
difficult to have then then who do you
trust if everyone's doing that so when
he says he likes loyalty doesn't mean
loyalty but you have to you know say
everything I say is right I don't agree
with everything the president's done I
agree with very much of that I think is
policy policies have been exceptional
you know sometimes his tone is different
than what I would use but I appreciate
that I like I like that he's Brash and
um I think sometimes we need a shaking
to wake us up and we needed that with
Trump just like with Reagan we needed a
calm cool optimism and a return toward
patriotism and love for Country we need
it with Trump someone to shake us out of
our Slumber because we got really lazy
and thought our country was on cruise
control and we found out it was but it
was going off a cliff uh I've disagreed
with him on things before we talk all
the time I just talked to him the other
day I talked to him two days ago we had
a long conversation and I didn't agree
with everything he said and we kind of
went back and forth on something and it
was it was fun how did you approach that
you said Mr President here's how I see
things differently like well not that I
need the actual conversation yeah but
like the tone the tenure like how do you
say well hey I am now okay you know what
he's a big boy he can handle it he wants
the truth he I've never seen anybody
like him and I've talked to people who
worked in the white house with them and
when there was an issue a problem he
would bring a whole group of people in
and say okay everybody I want your
opinion what do you think we should do
Tom how should we handle this do they
get it right yes Tom Adam what are your
thoughts on this Patrick how do you feel
Vincent what are your thoughts and then
he would make his decision what the
media has said about him is such a lie
it's been an eight-year slander and
smear campaign on one man we've never
seen anything like this in politics so
when I do approach people and they tell
me they don't like Trump I usually have
a conversation with them and I find out
they've just been believing the media
stories I actually fully believe that
the media has done Trump dirty no doubt
you know this is the chicken or the egg
thing you know fake news you being a
part of the media you have a very uni
unique Insight on this why do you think
it'll be any different this time around
if Trump is the president knowing what
you know about the media
well I think when we get president Trump
in office the people it is going to be
just so obvious that people are with
them and in the last since really
um kovid
and the 2020 election I will never
forget being on set that night reading
the election results and a producer
getting in my ear by the way and say
Brett Baer just called the election for
Biden in Arizona
um but this time around the people don't
because of all of that nonsense the
people have turned on the fake news
media and so they don't have it they
don't have the power they once had and
when they're trying to tear Trump down
this next go-around
it's not going to work it's going to
fall on deaf ears because it'll fall on
no ears not deaf ears no ears will be
listening and I also believe the Press
pool at the White House will be
comprised of a lot of the alternative
media
I mean maybe valuetainment will have a
reporter representing what's happening
at the White House so that the people
get the truth maybe we'll see you know
the Gateway pundit have a seat at the
table and and journalists who really
want to put out the truth and I I just
really think this next um term of
President Trump is going to be so
historic it's going to be a very quick
uh I don't even know the word Whiplash
is maybe the best word of turning it
around and I think we can do so quickly
I have I have great faith and hope that
our country is going to turn around but
we have to get president Trump in there
for that to happen I want to talk about
a couple things here uh with Newsome
okay so Newsome uh uh DeSantis and
Newsome will debate on Fox in November
they're really trying to push that two
Governors thing oh right but what is
that all about right so you know hey so
a governor is number Santos and Newsom
said to participate in a 90-minute
televised debate moderated by Fox with
Sean Hannity on November 30th the Santos
expresses anticipation for this debate
stating I look forward to the
opportunity to the big some over our
very different Visions for the future of
the country negotiations for debate
rules were initially styled for weeks
but both Governors have agreed to a real
debate not a circus the scientists
hinted that Newsome might become the
Democratic nominee in 2024 yep
presidential elections saying
California's leftism is kind of how the
Democratic party operates and this is
happening while Newsom is not a
candidate and DeSantis is behind 50
something points or you know whatever
the numbers are on different polls how
do you read this as a person say you're
not in politics today you're in media
today you read this story you're like
wait a minute why would you do so why
would Newsom do it why would the
scientists do it newsom's not running
why are you giving the platform do they
know something we don't know that they
think it's going to end up being the two
of them this is what uh this is the
dream the fantasy of the uni party we'll
have two governors of two board or not
border states actually one's a border
state we'll have the two God Governor's
East Coast West Coast we've got the you
know strong Governor versus the one who
destroyed California this is their
fantasy okay and I I don't think Joe
Biden's going to make it to the Finish
Line I think they're going to try to
toss him out of the vehicle and and then
have a uh maybe in the convention bring
Newsome in but um can you imagine
Newsome even thinking that he could run
for president he destroyed California
they have the phrase don't California my
Arizona have you heard that well they
have don't California my Florida don't
California my Texas Texas my Tennessee
my Iowa you name it the guy behind that
the reason that statement exists is
Gavin Newsom he has destroyed California
it was just in La about a week and a
half ago and we were in literally La in
Pasadena and I said this place almost
looks like a third world country the
size of the roads are filthy there's
people living in tents on the side of
the road buildings look like they
haven't seen uh paint in decades it is a
city that's falling apart Skid Row is
it's like an asylum an insane asylum on
the streets and a horror movie it's
almost as if the people who are on
strike in Hollywood have gone over to
Skid Row and you know created a horror
scene but it's sadly real life so
Gavin Newsom I I believe will never be
president because people don't like what
he did to California you don't think
he'll ever be president no you think he
will oh I think he's the most formidable
guy on the left I think to underestimate
him well maybe he's formidable on the
left and that tells you how bad the left
is the Democrat Party has fallen so low
that the guy responsible for turning the
Golden State into this
the people in California are actually
when I go and travel they're some of the
most
uh motivated for change because of him
and so this guy's just I have zero
respect for that man what he's done to
California and now do they think we're
dumb he's going to come out and try to
act like he's somewhere in the middle
and he's well let me read this let me
read this so here's two stories he's
running political this week yeah so
Newsome Vito's Progressive bill on
transgender children and self-driving
trucks okay so it's just surprising
vetoes that disappointed Progressive
allies including a rejection of a bill
assembly Bill 957 advocating
consideration of a child's gender
identity and custody disputes Newsome's
veto cited concerns about government
dictating legal standards and noted that
courts already considered parents
handling of gender identity dealing a
blow to lgbtq activist newsom's also
vetoed a bill mandating human drivers
and self-driving trucks a priority for
labor groups fearing automation economic
impact the governor defended his
decision by arguing that Regulatory
Agencies were better equipped to oversee
this emerging technology despite labor
Tom made a very good point at the
beginning of the podcast before we were
going live saying these are all signs of
a guy that's preparing for a 2024
election and he wants to be seen more as
Center well I hope the American people
don't lose their memory of what happened
during covid when that man destroyed
that was really the the final nail in
the coffin for California these
businesses they lost I I forget the
astronomical percentage of restaurants
Little Mom and Pop shops restaurants
were closed down for good what they did
to our children masking them up forever
they shut the beaches down remember when
they poured sand on the skate park you
couldn't surf because you the waves
might give you covet I mean what's going
to give you covet a shark
One Restaurant was open the French
Laundry was open that's right that's
right that incredibly I'm sure it's
great food it's incredibly expensive and
he was sitting there I believe without a
mask on yeah these Hypocrites and I hope
the American people it's gonna it's
gonna be reliant on us moms out there if
you've got moms watching right now we
cannot not forget this stuff that they
did to us we can't let them uh we can't
have amnesia and go well he's you know
he's going to be great he's a young guy
and no we can't we can't let that happen
I think that's who Trump will be running
against actually is Newsom I think
they'll find a way to put him in they
Biden's going to get us you know
butt handed to him
Vinnie do you want to read the senator
bobman and the story on what happened
with this guy very interesting story
first page page two right off the bat
it's right there if you go to the top
open it up it's the first story right
there right there if you open it up on
page two go one more page three right
there top story okay so you know what
story this is this guy's amazing he's I
mean he's a Democrat so he's going to
get away with whatever he gets can I say
something really quick because on that
on that um face off between DeSantis
let's let us not forget that DeSantis
also shut the beaches down DeSantis took
a page out of Gavin newsom's Playbook
despite what he says he shut the beaches
down he did Force vaccines
he did Force face masks on our kids so
he tries to act like he was perfect and
Florida was a Santa's Force vaccines on
kids he forced vaccines on people on
workers he forced face masks on children
and he was for all that DeSantis was for
all of that so he thinks that we forgot
that as well now granted he didn't
continue the misery as long was it one
month or a couple weeks on what it was
it was a little more than that it was a
little more than that the beaches were
shut down to people so anybody who shuts
a beach down I mean so so you so your
view of the santis do you see him you
how do you see the Santas there's a lot
of people that love him but you also
made a comment earlier about loyalty and
people that come and take what's good
from him Trump and then they leave and
they backstab him were you hinting at
the sentence or were you talking about
others he's definitely not loyal I mean
he president Trump made him president
Trump gave him an endorsement when he
was polling I think at five percent or
six maybe seven at the most and he
immediately shot up like a rocket ship
and because because of President Trump
uh he won and actually president Trump
saved Florida with an endorsement
whoever he would have endorsed was going
to win but remember DeSantis barely beat
that drug addict I don't know Andrew
Gillum was his name yeah he's like a
second before that it was uh Putnam in
the primary and that was uh but look
what's happening in Florida I've been
speaking to people in Florida and asking
what they think of the condition here
you can't is it 400 percent the
insurance rates have gone up
something really outrageous for the cost
of living has gone up because
everybody's moving here well a lot of no
question because of hurricanes if you
lose your house during a hurricane
um you're going to get Pennies on the
dollar for it there is an home owner's
insurance crisis here and it's the cost
of living has gone up uh a lot here in
Florida I mean I think it's great don't
get me wrong Florida's fantastic but I
don't think that's because Ron DeSantis
is Governor I think Florida is a great
place to live and I think it's actually
being become harder to live in Florida
as a guide that's a fan of uh both the
santis and Trump policies uh I can
comfortably say DeSantis uh is the
reason why we're here with the policies
and the lifestyle of Florida don't be we
love Breakers we love Florida we love
coming down here and doing what we do
here but he he had a lot of the good
policies that even the NBA felt safe
here Sports leaks felt safe here even
AOC parted here I mean even the left
would come here to party the policies
are affect the policy but but let me go
a little bit deeper with you just
curious so say Trump never endorses him
when he's at five six seven percent say
there's no endorsement like that at all
who is a governor DeSantis today there
is no endorsement who's Governor I think
he would have won I really don't believe
he would have won and I think he would
probably be trying to get back into
Congress you know but the other thing
the thing I have a problem with this is
somebody running for governor
um at the same time he was running and
he knew before he ran that he was going
to run for for president he didn't tell
people that I mean a few people knew but
he didn't tell the voter that and he
asked them to re-elect him and
immediately
and people did Trump supporters helped
re-elect him and he won and then
immediately he starts running against
Trump the people and then he took the
money that many Trump supporters donated
million dollars yes and put it over into
his pack what have them it could have
been 80 to 83 but it's a lot of money it
was I just anybody who makes a political
judgment like that when he he could have
walked in and been the president 28.
with hands down it was going to be Trump
and then a DeSantis term maybe two terms
as president and so he made the
political calculation to go up against a
giant a political giant like Trump that
tells me that's not a very smart person
what do you think told him okay because
we I asked this question to Pat once who
do you think was behind them because
like you just said if the Santa's
because he rocked as a as a governor
that's why Pat said you know I'm saying
we're all here if he just you know said
okay listen I'm gonna stay in the wings
I'll be your VP I'll I'll watch you I'll
learn how to speak publicly because
module when he speaks in Florida Gary
small little audiences he goes after
everybody and he's he's the Rhonda
sentence that that we though on the big
stage it's almost like he's he doesn't
know what he's doing because he's not
used to that that type that's a a really
great thing to look at now because he
everything was very controlled yes you
saw that you saw and that's why people
fell in love with him so like oh he did
a great job in that press conference he
really got him but you really didn't see
him did he ever do your show and speak
for two hours live with you who's this
did you ever see him go on Tim cast for
three hours and just get anything thrown
in he won't do that he's never
rescheduled God knows how many times
already every time it's like we're gonna
do it we're going to do it and it's like
something is coming I'm starting to
really believe after being peppered with
the craziest questions on a variety of
different media platforms that if you're
going to run for office if you can't
hold your own in a three-hour podcast I
agree yep that's when you really it's
hard to hold up if you've got if you've
kind of got your consultant points and
they're drilled into your head just to
be fair Trump's also not been a
three-hour podcast so if Trump is open
to a three-hour podcast I know a couple
people that would like to entertain
and I respect the hell out of you for
sitting here taking questions Left Right
Center that's something that Ron
DeSantis has not done yet
interview that was pretty long three
hours maybe you know he is a kind of
look Trump will go on CNN with Caitlyn
Collins we'll take tough questions
respect and say to say would Trump look
this is I know it's going to sound weird
what I'm about to say sis why I look I
just last week I had a very big debate
here discussion here we had two Muslims
sitting here we had two Christians
sitting here okay and it was very heated
it went all over the place a lot of
people you know saying things from the
conservative Muslim side from the
Christian side it was all over Twitter
okay there's been a few hundred reaction
videos to this podcast that we had I
want to sit down and have both sides
talk to one another right I got a lot of
respect for Newsome and Trump for one
thing Newsom will go sit down with
Hannity and have a discussion he has no
problem with that Newsome's not afraid I
don't agree with his problem you mean
for this debate he'll sit down with him
he'll he already did he's done two with
Hannity already I think he's done a
couple of them you have to ask what that
news Outlet whether it be fox or
whatever yeah is trying to accomplish
they are trying to set the stage they
are trying to set the stage in the mind
of America that these should be the two
candidates but you know you know what
I'm saying I don't disagree with you but
Brett Bear I mean sorry Sean hair and he
pushed him and you can't say that Sean
Hannah
can't say that Newsome held his own it
was very impressive on the way believe
me this outlet that you're talking about
once Newsome on the ballot they want
this set up and you have to realize when
they're even the people they allow on
who are they allowing on I don't
disagree either because I think you I
will tell you I I want to see Lakers
Celtics in a finals I don't want to see
no Milwaukee playing Phoenix I don't
want to see that one again
I'm not against the honest I think
Giannis needs to go to a bigger market
like New York I think he will next
couple years but going back to this here
with what we're talking about so I think
the the reason why I respect Trump is
because he'll say he's a gamer anywhere
Newsom I don't know if newsom's done
along I'd love to have Newsom here for a
couple hours to talk to him I think
Newsom has enough brass to do it so the
scientist hasn't shown he can do that I
think Fox probably wants a DeSantis
Newsom for one reason they can't stand
Trump from the you know uh pulse
reinside and Carl roadside you were
talking about earlier and I think it's
going to be a better matchup of Newsome
the Santa's future young that's kind of
how they see it they just don't like
Trump over there not everybody some of
them don't think they probably would
rather have Newsome than Trump a lot of
these people in the media as the
president
as a president well look at look at some
of these never trumpers who were
so-called Republicans who endorsed Biden
yeah Cindy McCain for starters endorsed
Biden oh you know who we're having on
next week you'll love this who's on here
next week Rob is it uh uh not next this
Friday no this Friday is Schmidt from uh
Steve Schmidt from uh you know who he is
it's going to be a wonderful uh Lincoln
project yeah we're gonna have a
conversation with them so we're gonna
see what Arizona but the Lincoln project
yes the Lincoln project folks so do you
want to do you want to read that Bible
no no no no trust me it's fine um so uh
Senator Bob Menendez faces increasing
calls from Democrats to resign following
his indictment in a bribery stream uh
New Jersey governor Phil Murphy and
Democratic lawmakers from the state
including reps uh Mickey Cheryl Bill
pasqurell Junior and Josh
gottheimer have called for his
resignation despite the cost of
recognition Menendez has asserted his
innocence labeling the charges as false
and attributing them to active smear
campaign pain of anonymous sources and
innuendos he has refused to step down
because he's a Democrat from the Senate
position standing I am not going
anywhere to be fair that thing doesn't
say everything because a Manhattan U.S
attorney office charged him with
accepting cash and gold bars yeah and
there's text messages and a car and a
Mercedes and they gave him so he's
saying oh I was just taking money out
and I was just I was holding it you know
it was kind of storing it and hiding it
in my closet yeah 100 I I still I still
love a lot of them
did you hear his reasoning though yeah
it's really not innuendos you said that
a lot of it was because it sucks his
lineage came from Cuba and that they
they understand that sometimes you need
to turn these things into things you can
run away with because they fled Cuba
60 years ago I mean that he's going the
full if you buy them right I think that
guy's got to go into sales yeah exactly
that Menendez accepted Cash Gold Bars
and other benefits in exchange for using
his office to benefit businessmen and
the Egyptian government that's probably
where the gold is is coming so what all
these people are selling out America
Egypt they're selling us out to the CCP
with the bidens and that crime family
I think everybody in DC I think Trump
just put this out on his truth social
everybody who's guilty or done something
like this they all should step down and
I don't think it's just Menendez and
Biden there's a lot of them there's a
lot of them on both the majority the
probably the majority in DC
have done something unethical like this
and this goes beyond unethical this is
just criminal if if he is convicted
so you see it's messages corrupted I I
don't disagree that it is by the way uh
a lady whose husband we hung out with uh
this last weekend so uh we are in this
is a crazy story so we're in New York
okay
I took 34 of my guys my friends my
Executives and I said let's go to New
York we went to 11 Madison we had dinner
there we won't comment on that we had
dinner at 11 Madison and then we had
afterwards we were trying to go to
Yankees game the next day and uh it
rained out so we said listen guys I had
my kids with me my son was turning 10
years old Dylan oh my gosh happy
birthday Dylan he was 210 years old so I
got my 11 10 my seven-year-old daughter
with me we got to show him a good time
so we go to this place called Chelsea
Piers phenomenal place we go way early
10 o'clock in the morning places like
wide open nobody said we get a bunch of
bowling lanes and we start having
conversations on who would you like to
have on the podcast Vinnie's talking to
me the door is behind me Vinny's here
Thomas here Sam is here Kim is here and
you're saying who would you want to have
and I look at Pat and mind you carry I'm
wearing when he says nobody's there I'm
talking about they're just setting up
getting ready literally nobody's there
nobody is there and by the he just
randomly goes hey kids where do you want
to chill it was a last minute decision
because of the game Pat's back to the
door like he said and then I just hear
kind of talking hey Vinnie who do you
think would be a good interview for me
to interview and I go right up I didn't
even have to take care I go Putin
questions why I go because he's such a
polarizing individual I would love to
hear that type of conversation from him
because Pat would push him with
questions he's a very interesting guy I
go Pat who would you want and I'm not
joking okay this is this is 100 God's my
witness I'ma standing right next Thomas
right there Pat goes you know what I
wouldn't I wouldn't be interested in
interviewing Hillary but you know what
Bill Clinton I'm not even joking Carrie
I just see a white hair guy walk in
three seconds and it's Bill Clinton I go
Pat remind me for my language I go Pat
Bill Clinton just walked into the effing
door the Pacos what the hell is going
very weird so Bill walks in then what
the Roblox
the secret Santa Monica the Secret
Service guy walks up and I go up to him
what are you doing in a bowling alley
goes do you know who my wife is he goes
anything I get away
there's like a a private party for some
kids which is great like 40 they were
having a private party and he walks in
and start talks to an older couple which
I guess he knew and then mind you carry
Secret Service five or six he's just
walking around by the way if Kerry for
two hours he went no joke he probably
shook by the time it was done there was
a bunch of people there he probably
shook 150 people easy understands he
understood
politics he's so smooth so Hillary his
wife okay very different sweetheart
right Hillary Clinton most likable
warrants she warns of potential Russian
election interference in 2024 and she
said he'll do it again can you please
play that clip and let's get a reaction
yeah that's exactly what it is if you
can play the Rob I thought you had the
clip prepared already you had it out
yeah
no he had it up already isn't Rob he's
over there working his butt off wow he's
a good kid oh this is the issue that's
the one the ginger swindler oh but Rob
that's three minutes and five seconds
one of these you pulled up earlier it
had the subtitles in Russian
I think it's the one on the bottom the
less than this one's 59 seconds okay
Preston let's see what she says she's
pretty long with them
obviously your friend your friend should
be fair
uh intervened in our election in the
past right it's not something as you
experience firsthand it's not something
we talk about a lot do you fear that
that is something that could be
happening for 2024. do you think we
should be talking about it more well I
think we should be thinking about it
more because I don't think despite all
of the uh you know deniers uh there's
any doubt anymore our election or that
he has interfered in many ways in uh the
uh Internal Affairs of other countries
funding political parties funding you
know political candidates uh buying off
uh you know government officials in
different places so that is his office
uh you know his his Opus operandi in the
sense that good one hates democracy he
particularly almost the west and he
especially hates us and he has
determined that he can do two things do
you guys do you guys understand what
like what's happening the gall of this
woman who was literally behind the
Russian collusion hoax about cheating is
over here warning us that Putin is gonna
do it this time like are you are you
kidding me like Is that real life
we're stuck in some sort of a loop right
now this whole country it's like they're
trying and the gas lighting has been so
off the charts and now they're going to
go completely with gas lighting like
this and it's just a repeat of what
they've been doing for the past eight
years oh there he is is that bill
look at them look at them look at that
shirt that shirt just says I'm going to
a bowling alley without my wife look at
that thing they would say fish shirt
with a blue blazer and a Ukraine flag no
he had a Ukraine flag on yeah he did
yeah he did and I didn't I didn't have
my Americans I would smoothness of ham
look at them that is working what he's
wearing just like an average Joe and
connecting with everybody we're not
answering the glaring question did you
ask him to be on the show uh no I did
not no but but the guy that was with him
the guy that was with him which was uh
very good to hear uh his secret service
guy was a fan of the show he watched a
podcast he says Mr David I watched a
podcast uh you you can approach
President Clinton and talk to him and we
had a very good conversation together my
wife
went to the same elementary school as he
did uh obviously not the same year
[Laughter]
um
here's my wife you know she's a
wheelchair
so anyways uh this is another joke of
another carry because uh but anyway so
uh yeah my wife and him went to the same
school so I said hey you know and he
said oh wow yes and then I also went to
your house and I noticed you were
recognized as the cutest baby you won an
award in 2010 and whatever the year was
yeah when he was two years old but in
the city we go to this Funeral House
okay and I go to this funeral home we're
there for a funeral my wife's dad passed
away so we're there for that reason Hope
Arkansas Hope Arkansas
so we go to this place and I say so tell
me uh how was uh Bill Clinton you know
what did you guys know about him in the
city and he says well what do you mean I
said is he the womanizer that people
claim he is he says of course he is
I said did you guys have a problem with
that he says you don't know who he's
married to yeah he says his wife he says
everybody here loves Bill he said well
let me tell you about his wife
he says one time Bill's uh Uncle dies
and he's up there giving a speech you
know there's a bunch of people there
says then Hillary sealed to the corner
she wanted to sit away from everybody
Bill's minklin with everybody I think
Bette Midler is there or something like
that
and he says afterwards they're going to
you know the plot to do the final you
know ceremony and she says we're there
with Secret Service security everybody
she said don't often expect me to go
there I'm going back home this is all
I'm going to do here you go handle the
rest I gotta go home says she was the
meanest person we ever met Hillary
Hillary obviously it's surprising you're
so shocked because I'm sure that's never
mind that smiles a lot right yeah but
you know you we don't know the whole
story there's a lot of different stories
behind it bill is a guy I would love to
have a long form conversation with I
would also like to talk to her I just
don't think she'd ever do it never no I
think she would only do a long
conversation with someone where there
were parameters set and you are going to
ask about this and they're on the same
team and I think a lot of these people
in the media are part of the kind of
deep State
um uni party they're they're in on it
all so if you would be willing to do
that I mean like I came on the show I
don't think that we had any parameters
no I don't I don't I usually tell people
I'll answer anything may not be the
answer you want but I'll answer anything
and I don't believe that Hillary would
do that if you want to start asking her
about the 30 000 emails that are missing
um bleach bidding or phones you know if
you want to start asking her about all
more difficult questions money and where
the money went in Clinton my interest
was more hair product is what I wanted
to ask about I wanted to ask about hair
products or the real estate of friends
and employees yeah that just that just
can't handle leaving and not working
with them so they just they kill them
the question is believe me when she
starts talking about you and she did
start talking about me toward the end
they were worried with the Katie Hobbs
thing
um you know Bill Clinton was talking
about Hobbes and and Hillary started
talking about me they had Eric Holder
come in and campaign and Bill uh Obama
came in and campaigned which was the
funniest by the way he said he was going
after me saying oh she looks good on TV
and she's good on television and she can
speak well and but Katie Hobbs chooses
not to look good she could look good but
she chooses not something is he actually
trying to give me an endorsement yeah
yeah but when Hillary Clinton starts
talking about you because of this
history you do tense up a little bit of
course you got to double down in
security oh boy let's check the brakes
on the car I'm in perfect health I'm not
suicidal you know she actually did yeah
so let's go to the next story Ted Cruz
okay says Dems could discard Biden for
Michelle Obama in 2024 which by the way
this was just a couple days ago
September 23rd it's not a you know a
story of a year ago or something like
that so some people have alluded to this
saying you said you were with Roger
Stone last night Roger fully believes
Michelle Obama is going to be the one
that's going to come in and he said this
to us multiple times so Texas Senator
Ted Cruz has raised the possibility of
them Democrat King makers might opt to
replace President Joe Biden for Michelle
Obama before 2024 I'm emphasizing uh
Biden's age crew stated on his podcast
verdict with Cruz that he views this
scenario as a very serious danger
Cruiser outline reasons why Michelle
Obama would be
could be an appealing choice for
Democrats including her popularity
amongst African-American women he
suggested that she could be parachuted
into the 2024 National DNC schedule for
August 2024 in our hometown of Chicago
as a way to avoid a divisive primary
potentially with the assistance of super
delegates as a way to avoid a divisive
primary no as a way to avoid
the vetting of candidates
our candidates should be vetted this the
whole process is about vetting a
candidate and so you know parachuting in
is a really convenient way of not being
asked tough questions of allowing the
media to just you know go Gaga over
somebody I would need I as a voter and I
hope that Democrat voters would want
more
vetting on where do you stand on the
issues what and there's been a lot of
corruption from the Obama campaign was
very corrupt
and there needs to be some questions
asked of that but the media will never
ask tough questions of Obama you saw the
interview that Tucker did the man who
made accusations yes many years ago it
was out there he took a you know lie
detector test he spoke out about his um
you know sexual relationship with with
uh Obama and drug use yeah and the media
never covered it they knew about it and
they never covered it they were told if
you covered this you will never have an
interview with Obama you will be iced
and the media never covered that can you
imagine if that came out credible they
they take sources that aren't credible
that are just plain lying it's really
obvious the facts don't back them up and
with Trump and they run all kinds of
crazy stories but that never got play
so I don't like the idea of someone
parachuting in but I don't think I still
don't think it'll work by the time the
election rolls around the way I see it
the American people are going to be so
tired of the Democrat policies and if
they think it's going to be any
different under Gavin Newsom or Michelle
Obama than it is under Biden who do you
think is more formidable and more likely
who I I kind of think that
um more formidable meaning I mean I
don't have a chance of winning Michelle
or Newsom has more of a chance than
winning and who's more likely of
actually being the one in 2020. either
of them have a chance of winning but as
far as who would the Democrats pick I I
think maybe Newsome
over Michelle that's kind of racist
isn't it
so funny I I just I'm not sure I've
never really heard her speak on the
issues so I don't know that you know
other than you know very controlled
situation why do you think people are
saying I mean I'm just throwing the dart
here Michelle has never once indicated
that she's gonna run I have friends on
both sides of the aisle friends that are
on the left who are like dude there's no
chance he's running why does it still
continue to be propagated by even the
Ted Cruzes of the world or maybe if it's
really bad and they're thinking oh my
gosh Trump's going to win by such a
landslide they will put Michelle in
because it it would be harder I think
because of the you just said I'm racist
for saying that it might be news no what
I'm saying is that's what they said they
would say yeah it was a joke no I know
you were joking but there is that sense
of you can't ask tough questions because
if you are a journalist you might be
accused of being racist if you so maybe
they're if they're really in dire
situation they might put Michigan it
could be Michelle and Kamala what oh my
God I would 100 interesting yeah
Michelle Obama speaks in front of Arenas
I'm telling you right now if they just
came out and they said hey Michelle's
running trust me bro she would get she
would get in the votes but Gary quick
question because we did a really fast uh
Tucker did have Larry Sinclair we were
thinking about motive and Pat made a
great question of why would Tucker out
of all times of all people because he
could interview anybody from Elon Musk
said whatever why why bring the the guy
that accused him the module you said it
signed an affidavit if I had to lie
detector test twice that said that all
these all these things happened do you
think it was a move on Tucker because he
hates the establishment so much care
that he was like you know what just just
to let you guys know I'm having this guy
come up Joe just in case Michelle does
run you're gonna have to address this
because they were hiding Michelle left
the country and Barack was M.I.A nobody
even they couldn't even reach the left
never asked any questions of them after
that is that weird and even cover it if
they they just attacked Tucker yeah
exactly so do you think it's like a it's
like a move on Tucker just because has
kind of that power to be like okay I
just did this because if she does
announce there's more of this you're
gonna have to talk and address this guy
because that guy's not going anywhere
could be that could be right that
they're seeing that the Obamas might
make a repeat appearance yep so now you
have a little bit of ammunition because
you know I mean as we all know Tucker is
not establishing well the interesting
thing this time around is last time they
had the media just as I said I was in
when I went and did the interview with
Obama which I thought was a more tough
interview because most people aren't
ever don't ever ask him a question that
he wouldn't want most people in
journalism the entire press pool was so
enamored with Obama they don't ask they
didn't ask to have questions of him
nothing and then a year later when I was
there at the at the uh Trump White House
it was like everybody was on Attack Mode
they were on steroid Attack Mode
it was just the strangest thing
or never ask a tough question of the
Obamas but this time around that media
does it that media exists however
there's also the alternative media and
if they think those questions aren't
going to be answered this time around I
think they have another thing coming
yeah and I love your the the comparison
have you seen the White House Press
briefings now with Korean Jean-Pierre
it's quiet Peter Ducey asked one
question she shuts them down they move
on Donald Trump when they had like Sarah
hucker be in there it was a show
sorry for my language it was Insanity
people yelling Jim Acosta this person
running to the front it was insane now
they all know don't don't ask crazy
questions it's insane how to see not
even crazy just questions that are going
to be uh pointed and getting to the
truth if you because I think Peter
ducey's questions are all legitimate 100
100 I think he does a great job he does
a great job but he but here's the thing
carries some would say okay he asked
these questions and then what nothing
ever happens just the other day he goes
uh uh Karine what do you call 10 000 in
illegals coming over order and she
answers with a question and she says
what do you call the GOP goes no no she
goes oh no no you're not answering I try
to answer and she leaves and nobody this
is what bothers me Pat that happens she
doesn't answer the question Carrie not
one of these so-called reporters goes no
no hold on a second I want you to answer
answer that question what do you call
ten thousand people coming here 13 000 a
day it's an invasion that's what it is
they're coming to invade Us and nobody
holds their foots to the fire so Peter
Ducey he asked the questions nothing
happens zero because the the group that
controls who goes into the White House I
forget the name of the actual group uh
they won't let serious journalists in
they only want people who are going to
have the same ideology and they have to
let fox in and thank God Peter Ducey
asked the tough questions but that's
about the only there's a couple there's
that
um I don't remember his name he's uh
he's a reporter but I believe from
Africa and he has tough questions yes
they kicked him out once they took his
credentials and then I guess they
brought him back in well yeah she hated
Simon right
Rob did he get his credentials back
because I'm pretty sure they kicked him
up because he would he would talk over
her and not let her just blow over him
he's like no no answer the question well
listen uh Carrie this has been fantastic
having you on uh I know you have a book
that just came out unafraid we're gonna
put the link below for people to go
order the book but didn't show us a
start a podcast aren't you you got
something going on with the dude yeah
tell us about it so it's a weekly and I
actually did a couple of interviews
while I was in town here clerical this
will be coming up it's just a weekly you
know I want to I love being a journalist
I love asking questions I love hearing
people's story so it's just a way to
continue to do that and you know a once
a week show is a lot easier to do than a
daily as you all know so that's um you
can see that and I put it out everywhere
I put it on my Rumble page I put it on
Twitter so the next one's coming up I'm
not sure which one we're going to be
dropping next but it's sure to be
exciting I I have a Roseanne interview
that I just did I talked to Eric Trump
Roger Stone got a few more things up
myself so very cool well we're going to
put the link below to the website as
well probably the best place to follow
it'll drive to everything else and make
sure to order the book Carrie keep up
the fight it's great seeing you
everywhere you're a super necessary
voice thank you and thank you for having
the courage to talk about these issues
that are taboo now they're really
important I want our country to be
strong I want our future to be strong
and without fighting some of these
fights that are difficult then we won't
have a country so thank you all anytime
we're with you so uh I believe
Wednesday's the debate Rob Wednesday
night will be the debate at the Ronald
Reagan Library you will be there yes we
may be there and then Thursday morning
we uh uh may do a reaction podcast here
uh we'll let the audience know what's
going to be happening but that's going
to be happening this weekend and Friday
we definitely have a podcast or two I
think Marianne Williams Williamson's
also going to be here on Friday we got
everybody coming left right middle
Center Muslim Christian doesn't matter
what to talk to right that's what we
want to do that's what I think media
should be all about have a great one
everybody we'll see you guys on Thursday
take care bye bye